[Música]
a principios de mayo el ejército iraquí
llevó a cabo una ofensiva para desalojar
a los combatientes yazidíes de la región
de xinjiang en el noroeste de irak estas
son las unidades de resistencia de
sillar compuestas por combatientes
yazidíes una minoría de habla kurda no
musulmana esta milicia fue creada en
2014 para luchar contra el
autodenominado estado islámico pero
estos combatientes ahora se niegan a
desmovilizarse y se han instalado en
zonas civiles de shinya asustados por
los combates miles de yazidíes han
vuelto a huir de sus pueblos cuando
estallaron los combates el 2 de mayo
nuestro observador se encontraba en casa
de su tío en el pueblo de sheen uno
llame a uno de mis amigos y me dijo que
el ejército iraquí estaba atacando las
unidades de resistencia de sillar con
tanques y helicópteros había
combatientes de las unidades de
resistencia de singer atrincherados en
una escuela entonces el ejército iraquí
atacó la escuela
[Música]
la gente estaba aterrorizada
después de eso huimos en auto en el
camino también vi a muchas familias
huyendo hacia la montaña y los pueblos
que no fueron afectados por los combates
y vamos 22 personas en el vehículo
después fuimos a un campo de refugiados
en kurdistán
muchos yazidíes y habían tenido que huir
a campamentos ante la amenaza yihadista
en 2014 las condiciones de vida en estos
campamentos son precarias afectadas por
cortes de agua e incendios desde que
cesaron los combates el 3 de mayo los
jóvenes yazidíes enfurecidos organizan
manifestaciones periódicas en el pueblo
de simón para denunciar los combates en
las zonas civiles y exigir el
restablecimiento de la seguridad
exigen la retirada de todas las fuerzas
armadas de los pueblos solo piden la
presencia de la policía local y nacional
la región designar estos pueblos los
pueblos ya civiles no son para nada
seguros actualmente de los ya civiles
que habían regresado a sus hogares y que
están volviendo a kurdistán
recientemente sólo entre el 10% y el 15%
de ellos han vuelto a sus casas en los
últimos días
cinco años después de la final de la
ofensiva contra el estado islámico más
de 193 mil residentes de sillar y así
díaz kurdos y árabes aún no han
regresado a sus casas
desde el comienzo de la guerra en
ucrania la reacción de los observadores
de france24 ha estado investigando las
noticias falsas que circulan en el marco
de este conflicto hay un tema que suele
surgir con mucha frecuencia las
acusaciones de nazismo dirigidas a
ucrania y a los ucranianos el propio
vladimir putin dice que la invasión rusa
tiene como objetivo la desnazificación
de ucrania estas acusaciones se basan
sobretodo en la existencia del batallón
a soft que ahora forma parte del
ejército ucraniano pero que ha sido
señalado por tener entre sus filas a
numerosas figuras de extrema derecha
incluidos algunos neonazis el batallón
afirma ya no tener este tipo de
combatientes otros señalan también que
durante la segunda guerra mundial
nacionalistas ucranianos como stepán
bandera colaboraron abiertamente con la
alemania nazi y es a partir de esas
alegaciones que se propagan las noticias
falsas en imágenes vean este ejemplo
no creo y niña porque esto
para todos dólares
la bandera con la esvástica en este
centro comercial de kiev sería la prueba
de la supuesta simpatía de ucrania por
el nazismo aunque este vídeo es real fue
grabado el 18 de febrero de 2019 y no en
el marco de la actual guerra entre rusia
y ucrania lo más importante es que el
centro comercial se había disculpado y
había explicado lo ocurrido queremos
disculparnos por la situación ocurrida
con la escalera led de nuestro centro
comercial nuestro sistema informático
fue hackeado la dirección y el personal
no apoyan de ninguna manera estas
acciones cuando no se trata de vídeos
sacados de contexto es el presidente
ucraniano volodymyr selenski quien es
atacado
algunos lo acusaron de mostrar en su
camiseta un símbolo utilizado por los
nazis la insignia de los caballeros de
la cruz de hierro una de las más altas
distinciones militares del tercer reich
pero esta no es la cruz de hierro sino
el emblema de las fuerzas armadas
ucranianas la principal diferencia es
que la cruz ucraniana tiene los lados
rectos mientras que la cruz de hierro
utilizada por los nazis tiene los lados
más redondos así que no es el mismo
símbolo
por último aquí un último ejemplo que
señala incluso a los refugiados
ucranianos en europa esta acusación
viene directamente del gobierno ruso ya
que la embajada rusa en letonia publicó
estas fotos en su cuenta de 'twitter' a
principios de mayo la embajada critica
los malos comportamientos de los
refugiados ucranianos que según ellos
exhiben símbolos nazis el hombre que
vemos en pantalla uso una chaqueta con
el logo del batallón a soft acusado de
tener combatientes neonazis pero el
hombre de la foto desmintió la situación
en su página de facebook podemos
confirmar que se trata del mismo hombre
comparando los tatuajes que se ven en
las fotos de la embajada y en la página
de facebook es letón y no es un
refugiado ucraniano a pesar de esta
aclaración el tweet sigue publicado en
la cuenta de la embajada rusa en letonia
si usted ha visto una foto o un vídeo
dudoso que quiere verificar envíenos los
por mensaje privado a la cuenta de
twitter de info o intoxica tro
y así es como llegamos al final de los
observadores por esta semana recuerde
que si ha sido testigo de un
acontecimiento lo ha grabado o ha visto
circular en imágenes se puede poner en
contacto con nosotros ya que todos
nuestros datos aparecen en pantalla
finalmente agradecer a coffee mosaic
house por prestarnos un espacio para
realizar la grabación de este episodio
siga con más información en france24
france24 puntocom hasta pronto